today is a day for truth the world needs
to know what happened and to know what
he stands for that kind of power is very
dangerous let the record show that this
committee holds him responsible that's
how it starts a fever the rage that
turns good men cruel
this bat vigilantes like a one-man rite
of terror you don't get to decide what
the right thing is nobody cares about
Clark Kent taking on the Batman
he has the power to wipe out the entire
human race
now I have to destroy
God vs Man
Dave versus night
the red capes are coming the red capes
are coming
you
hey youtubers is charlie so a couple you
guys asked me to do a trailer video for
this Wonder Woman WTF trailer i'll
explain what's going on it's all about
movie licensing there's also a prequel
comic that I'm going to explain to
that's right if you guys didn't know
there's actually a prequel comic that is
can into the movie that says up some of
the stuff that's going on explains some
of the plot points but starting with the
Wonder Woman moment so the WTF the
reason i call it WTF is because Wonder
Woman is flying what looks like Coach on
a plane why is Wonder Woman flying on an
airplane turkish airlines to be specific
with all their logos in clear frame well
there are a couple different answers but
it all boils down to advertising
integration the companies will pay
millions of dollars sometimes to have
their logos appear in movies or even
become plot points like it depends on
how much money you pay one of the best
examples is GM paying to have their cars
be the transformers in the transformer
movies that's a really big plot point so
obviously they probably paid a lot more
money than turkish airlines did to get
their planes into Batman V Superman but
you can kind of hear the conversations
happening at Warner Brothers hey Turkish
Airlines just offered us 5 million
dollars to use their airplanes in our
film how are we gonna do that well
wonder woman might be in that part of
the world she hears craziness happening
in America so she need to get back
everybody hates Superman who flies
around like a god so maybe she's trying
to stay under the radar but then I can
hear all you guys raising your hands in
the background wait a minute doesn't the
world already know about wonder woman
isn't she supposed to be like 4,000
years old yes and if she's integral in
stopping world war one the world would
know about her but there's a number of
different ways to explain why she
doesn't just fly to America when she
wants to help with this craziness and
you have to remember too that not
everything from the trailers makes it
into the final cuts of movies all the
trailers really meant to do is sell
people on the film like hey I gotta go
see this this is amazing so sometimes
they will shoot things specifically for
the trailer that they never intend to
put in the movie so we don't even know
this is actually going to be in the
movie it would make sense that they
would cut something like this out
because Wonder Woman clearly has her
powers so it'd just be confusing to see
her writing coach so I'm going to go
ahead and guess that they just shot this
for the trailer it was just meant to be
an ad integration in related ad
integration news all you serial fans out
there may have seen that they're doing a
Batman V Superman 0 there to differ
boxes General Mills usually this stuff
targets little kids so you'd expect
there be action figures in the cereal
boxes but the price is actually a comic
book that is a prequel to Batman V
Superman that does explain some of the
craziness that's going on Batman and
Wayne Enterprises has been experimenting
with Kryptonian technology there's all
kinds of stuff going on in the film that
they're going to use these tie-ins to
explain it's the same deal with Star
Wars Star Wars uses a lot of expanded
material to explain things that they
don't explore in the film so the comic
book itself is called field day and it's
all about this character named Zoe going
on a field trip with her school to Wayne
Enterprises like you'd expect a little
kid to do she sneaks away from the tour
group and tries to see some of the
really cool stuff and Wayne Enterprises
she runs into a group of thieves that
are also in Wayne Enterprises trying to
steal Kryptonian technology and weaponry
Bruce Wayne is there the Zoe character
and he both get captured Superman shows
up and demands that they returned the
Kryptonian technology to him because it
belongs to his people they give him the
middle finger Bruce Wayne goes bad ass
takes them down return Zoe to her tour
group what it does is for shadows some
of Bruce Wayne's thinking in Batman V
Superman you're like a lot of people who
get power they didn't earn you don't
know anything about using it responsibly
sooner or later you'll discover you have
more limitations than you think
limitations sounds like a big kryptonite
teaser there's also another prequel
comic that you can get off of dr. pepper
cans you have to scan it with a nap and
it'll unlock it it does pretty much the
same thing as the field day comic does
just set up a little bit about what's
going on with Batman's character creates
a little more context for what's going
on in Gotham City some familiar villains
like Firefly here he's a five-part comic
so I guess you gotta drink a lot of soda
or scan a lot of cans to unlock it but
don't worry you don't need to read them
to understand what's going on in the
movie I would recommend that you try the
serial out but let me know what you guys
think about these ad integrations in the
prequel comics do you like the idea of
them doing the Star Wars thing where
there's expanded material that explains
characters that they don't necessarily
explain in the movies but you have to
get other products to find that out I
feel like it only works if you don't
absolutely have to read these expanded
things to understand what's going in the
movie if that were the case I feel like
everybody be rioting in the streets but
if you got to eat breakfast cereal why
not eat Batman V Superman cereal and
learn a little bit more about
movie in the process I know the Super
Bowl is coming up really soon there are
reports the Batman V Superman is going
to skip it but they'll probably do
something online around the Super Bowl
there just won't be an ad during
halftime DC is going to save itself like
10 million dollars for a 30-second ad so
you can't be mad at them for that the
movie is coming out so close to the
Super Bowl there's no point in them
doing a Super Bowl ad there will be a
bunch of Fox and Marvel stuff so x-men
captain america civil war maybe
something else too whatever ends up
happening I will totally do videos for
it so be sure to subscribe to get that
stuff while you guys wait for my next
video to post in case you haven't seen
it I just posted a funny Deadpool
trailer you can click here to watch that
and you can click here to watch all my
Suicide Squad Batman V Superman videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you